okay good morning everybody we're gonna
get going here
um
we'll ask representative Guthrie to lead
us in the pledge this morning please
okay you're going to ask the clerk to
call the roll please
Vice chairman power present
representative Guthrie
clerk is here representative Los Angeles
here
representative Keller here
representative Kelly here
representative colcom here thank you
representative Cahill present
representative
representative Tatro here representative
Trey 11.
representative Gilman here
representative majority here
representative mangaputi
present
representative Gallagher
here representative Hicks I'm here
representative Highland here
representative priests here
and chairman turkey here
excuse me but my name was not called
my apologies representative no problem
thank you
okay good morning everybody going to
open up the
executive session on HB 44 relative to
permissible residential units in a
residential Zone
and I will look towards representative
Cahill for a motion
yes I would like to make a motion to itl
House Bill 44 relative to permissible
residential units in a residential Zone
do we have a second
second
representative Elward seconds
representative Cahill would you like to
speak to your motion
yes thank you Mr chair
House Bill 44 seeks to take away a lot
of local control
zoning boards have obviously already
established as a process which people
can apply for what house bill 44 seeks
to do and for that reason I think that
we should ideal it
thank you representative anybody else
representative Gilman thank you Mr chair
uh it should be 44
provide some
um
extra property rights it it increases
the property rights for single family
lots uh
there are restrictions on this um
on the proposal that has the the units
have to meet the setbacks whatever the
municipality has in their zoning
ordinance and the amendment which we
haven't spoken of includes parking that
parking requirements must be met and it
also changes the date of uh
its effective date into 20. the member
will suspend we are at this point only
talking about the the bill not the
amendment
thank you Mr chair
the um
the positive things about this bill is
that it will be a tool not everybody is
going to use this tool but it will be a
tool to provide more housing in
communities it requires that the units
be connected to Municipal Water and
Sewer if there is some if not
you would stick to the regular zoning of
your municipality I know there's concern
about whether or not this will overwhelm
a municipalities Water and Sewer process
or process processing I think that there
is a trigger point where that can be
reviewed perhaps at the building permit
adding units to a single-family prob
property don't necessarily have to go
through site plan design and review but
if we have it as a checkpoint on the
building permits to review for the your
water and sewer department or whoever is
in charge of the connections then that's
where a building could be or additional
units can be denied based on the
incapacity of the system to handle it
and then the municipalities can decide
if they want to go forward and expand
what they already have
I think this is a good way to start
providing the housing that this this
state is looking for and as I said
before it expands the property rights on
a single family lots and also provide it
could provide an income stream for those
owners that want to stay in place age in
place but need some income to cover
their taxes I think there's plenty good
about this with the restrictions that
are very clear if your zoning ordinance
has setbacks Etc you must comply with
them there is no way out of that unless
you go to the zoning board and even then
there has to be a strong a very strong
argument for why these additions and
divisions should happen
thank you representative Kellum
thank you
I see that the that some people would
like the local municipalities to have
um
over uh that the state needs to um
limit the over regulation of our housing
and as someone that is on the housing
board or the housing special committee
at at the State House I think that
housing is
is in large part being
reduced by municipality over regulation
and I do agree with the previous
representative that this is increasing
the property rights of those the the
individuals that we are trying to
protect and
and serve in our communities and the
municipality may be through honest error
or just because they like Central
planning are over uh regulating their
community in and causing each Community
is contributing to the the housing
shortage that we have and each one wants
to claim it's everyone else and and I
think that the state has an absolute uh
responsibility to
ensure that that these local
municipalities are not over regulating
unnecessarily when uh you know there's
uh no safety or
um or uh harm being done to uh no safety
concerns or harm being done by
additional people living in their
community so thank you
representative manager booty
thank you Mr chair thank you for
um
my two senses very similar to the
previous two speakers this is another
tool for in the toolbox for the
communities to enhance or increase more
dwellings right now when we are in
crisis
and um you know somebody who's in that
cusp of
you know trying to downsize this gives
an option for
multi-generational and dwelling or stay
an age in place it's a win-win for all
around and I look at the support
uh the testimonies there were
quite a few support except one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve who spoke in support two
in opposition and then sign on was 10
support and none in opposition so we are
really doing the work of constituents
and what our members want to want us to
do and this
it very clearly states that only with
the municipal sewer and water so it's
not adding additional burden to any
Community if it cannot take and it only
enhances the community and I strongly
urge that we pass this with uh ought to
pass so
um I will be opposing itl
representative Howell
so I I support this bill I think it
really strikes a good balance between
property owner rights and uh local
control and by that um over regulation
often turns uh uh this type of
development into a no it's not even a
conversation that you can have and that
really impinges upon the uh the asset of
the property owner they're not able to
maximize the value of their most
consequential uh item and so I think uh
the community still has the power with
setbacks Heights and that to regulate
but the conversation as I said changes
from no to how does this actually fit in
our community and I think it really
Spurs on the planning board then to
begin to look at local regulations and
to think about how you can add housing
that fits into the existing uh the
existing community in an existing
neighborhood so I think it's a really
good bill and I support it
representative power
thank you Mr chairman I support the
motion of itl because the bill has
written it unilaterally preempts local
land use controls and also has the
potential to avoid local a master plans
that towns have adopted I um
I support these types of decisions being
made at the local level in the local
municipalities they are there they
understand the the the
I guess the lay of the land if you will
in the municipalities and for this type
of a decision to be made here at the
state level I don't think it's the best
um
solution and additionally under current
rsas
individuals can go before their zba and
and ask for permission to do what this
bill bill seeks to do and again that
would be made at the local level not
here at the state level
representative priest
thank you Mr chairman I am for this bill
and against the itl motion and I
basically agree with what has been said
so far by all the supporters of this
bill but I want to stress the fact that
we have a housing crisis in New
Hampshire it is affecting our Economic
Development
um and none of the communities are
really taking on the responsibility to
address this problem
and this problem is going to get worse
this bill is one tool that has to happen
and it provides
the ability for the property owner to do
this if he meets certain
regulations Water and Sewer setbacks and
all of that
the communities are not losing their
right they're gaining they're they're
they're able to provide the housing to
their Workforce and to to kind of lessen
the crisis that we have currently
thank you
thank you representative further uh
representative
um so yeah I support this bill and
oppose the motion of Ito on it
um
some just some additional points I'd
like to bring up as
just a personal anecdote my brother
lives in Portland Oregon in a fourplex
like this type of Bill would allow by
right and um
it's a very nice type of housing I've
gone out to visit them and it works
perfectly for him and his fiance and
their current living situation
um
and so so
um yeah I support building more of this
type of Housing and
um as for the bill itself
um so
it's already
uh a very compromising very much a
compromised Bill like it's watered down
a lot from
previous versions
um
if if I had my way and
could
enact legislation unilaterally I would
just say four plexes are allowed by
right full stop and not include any of
the
other stuff about
having to meet parking requirements and
whatever but
since I'm not and we have to make
compromises here in the legislature we
included those
um provisions
so to address people's concerns about
local control so I think that shows
that we are taking
those concerns seriously and I think
um
you know there are a lot of
local planning boards
out there who might be kind of
protesting
now um about it but are really just
um waiting for us to tell them to do to
start allowing fourplexes and will be
perfectly fine with it once we do pass
this so
um
yeah I I I don't really see any
great harms that this bill will cause I
I think it will only be a benefit and
therefore support this
um support this legislation
for the comments
seeing that I'll make uh one I will
support the ITIL oh I'm sorry
um
representative
thank you Mr chair I would just like to
I think I need to correct uh
representative manager Puti in the
support of this bill
um on the remote sign-in we had 83
support 83 signed into support uh four
for a pose in opposition and three
neutral and I think that these numbers
matter thank you
thank you
um the comment I was going to make there
are a lot of issues that I have
personally with the bill some of them
have been discussed some haven't
ultimately for me it comes down to the
to the issue of local control this
mandates from a top-down to these cities
and towns that you must do this that is
something that those cities and towns
can do on their own without being forced
to uh from above so I will support the
ITIL motion
so you know further comments could we
ask the clerk to call the role
HP 44 itl uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes
representative Silas yes
representative your Keller no
representative Kelly yes
representative Elwood yes
representative Cumby
sorry about that I apologize
representative Cahill yes
Representatives Davis no
representative Tatro no
representative Trail Evans no
um
a percent of each 11 may not vote on
this particular motion she was not in
the room when the motion was made you
are correct sir sorry about that my
apologies to the committee
uh representative Gilman no
representative majority no
representative megapody
no
representative Gallagher
representative Hicks no
representative Howland now
representative Priest No
and the chairman yes
uh motion fails uh 10 to 9. thank you Mr
clerk we have a another motion
I move out to pass
everyone everyone on this second
I second four percent of priests was
second
further discussion
see
madam
representative priest could you turn off
your mic
for what
reason do you you were going to speak on
this a question yes uh wasn't there a
question to the chair isn't there uh
amendment to this or no the motion was
made ought to pass that was the motion
made
seeing no other questions could it have
the clerk call a roll
Mr chair
um point of order or
I'm it's a question sure and it concerns
the amendment
um
and I'm wondering if we can vote on the
bill before voting on the amendment the
motion was made to vote on the bill so
that's the motion on the floor you can
still make a motion to uh to yeah to um
bring them up to bring the amount of
yokella you were not recognized to speak
so if you have the amendment
representative of your color
the motion on the floor is ought to pass
we'll dispose of this motion and then if
there's I withdraw the motion thank you
very much Mr chair
uh
who who made the motion on that
um
okay all right the motion has been
withdrawn do we have a motion on the
floor representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair I would like to move
otpa
be interesting
so I think we have to thank you consider
the amendment separately okay
okay we have to I would draw that motion
okay all right let's talk about how this
is gonna go
if the goal is to do an otpa the first
thing we should do is have a motion on
an amendment to introduce an amendment
so is there somebody who would like to
motion
an amendment representative priests I
would like to make a motion to approve
the amendment for this bill
what is
before we have a second what is the
amendment number on this bill
representative please I don't have that
in front of me
I do have it now it's Amendment
2023-00298 thank you okay I have a
motion to accept the amendment two zero
two three zero zero two nine H do I have
a second representative stavis
yes which we do
thank you
is there any discussion on the amendment
see
represent uh Power I have a question Mr
chair sure
um could somebody speak to the amendment
and explain what the amendment does I
believe the individual who made the
motion on the amendment should speak to
it
representative priests
this amendment answers the questions
that have been raised regarding HB 44.
and I think you have a copy in front of
there any further discussion
representative Gilman thank you Mr chair
I I think that the amendment further
clarifies the
limitation that uh each Community can or
has or may have on the parking amount
per dwelling unit it also expends or
changes the enabling
or effective date I'm sorry to uh 2024
in order to give towns uh time to
prepare and be ready to know the answer
to whether they can EX
have the capacity for such new units
representative power
thank you Mr chairman um before us we
have an amendment and I don't believe
that all committee members have a copy
of the amendment
so I will not be supporting this
amendment
representative for the comments
representative yokella the amendment
um was given at the hearing and
discussed at the hearing so it is not
the fault of the member to uh ship to
redistribute the amendment that you
already previously were given so I don't
believe that is a valid criticism of the
amendment proposal thank you
I believe representative yokella when we
speak to bills or amendments we
uh never mind anybody uh represent
manager Puti thank you uh Mr chair I
echo my pre uh colleague who spoke
previously I had this amendment attached
to the bill from the public hearing
times so it was handed out along with uh
when before the prime sponsor
presented the bill and so we've had it
and that answered some of the questions
and so it is a domain and so I will
definitely support it thank you thank
you
see no further discussion because do we
have the role uh clerk color role please
okay our Amendment 2023-0029h
uh representative power no
representative Guthrie
clerk votes no
Representative lasalles no
represent your Keller yes
representative Kelly
representative Elwood no
representative cocom
no
representative Cahill no
Representatives Davis yes
representative Tatro
representative Trey 11.
thank you everyone yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes
Mr chairman nope
uh motion passes 11 to 9. do we have a
further motion
representative Gilman
do we have a second representative three
seconds the motion is there any further
discussion seeing nothing none will lead
clerk call a role representative
mangaputi please turn off your
microphone thank you
foreign
okay uh
ought to pass as Amendment as amended in
the amendment is
2023-0029 H
Vice chairman of power no
representative Guthrie
collect votes no Representative lasalles
no
representative yokella yes
representative Kelly no
representative Elwood no
representative kolkum
no
no representative Cahill now
representative stavis yes
representative Tatro yeah
representative tree 11 yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes
representative priest yes
and the chairman no
motion passes eleven to nine
thank you Mr Clark uh motion passes 11
to 9.
the committee report I'm assuming this
will not go on
the consent calendar I move consent
it's not out of order it's out of order
sir
um
who will be writing the committee
reports
representative Gilman okay
foreign
and with that we will close the exact
session on hb44 a comment on reports
um any of those coming out of here today
um
for our side of the aisle here have them
to me by
five o'clock tomorrow
and
your side of the aisle Representatives
Davis make sure they have everything to
you so you can get it to me by
approximately 5 pm thank you
representative power you have a question
thank you Mr chairman I wanted to know
if there will be a um
Minority Report
or opposing report there will be that
will be written by myself okay
okay with that we'll open up the here uh
exact session on hb99
requiring tax bills to provide
information about state tax rebate
and I believe we have a motion from
representative treeleven thank you Mr
chair uh we do have a motion I do have a
motion just before that I want to
express my sincere apology for my
Outburst yesterday to Madame Vice chair
and Mr chair I feel very strongly about
language and we need to use the correct
words to label things and I was
definitely out of order so please accept
my apologies
thank you representative you're welcome
accepted you're welcome and your motion
thank you um I move that we
um vote to itl and expected to legislate
uh
hb99 do we have a second representative
Davis seconds
is there any discussion could I speak to
my motions you may thank you very much
Mr chair
um while this is a well-intentioned
idea to inform
lower income
homeowners about the possibilities of
tax rebates
you know not a rebate a waiver on the
amount of tax they have to pay or a
waiver on their assessment
it's it's too unwieldy it's not fair to
towns and cities to require them to put
this sort of information on every single
solitary
um
tax bill it also may be discriminatory
because we're talking about
people who will be
labeled
as low-income homeowners and that's
that's really not fair
um the information that people need when
they are in a category in which they
might receive help from the state or the
town possibly even the community is
readily available and If the
sponsors of the bill would come back and
maybe propose oh
you know a line on a tax bill that would
say if you need help contact XYZ program
or community service
that might be workable but this in its
state is its current uh proposal is is
not workable and it becomes here's that
lovely word two words unfunded mandate
because it certainly will cost person
hours and time and materials to
produce this information on the tax
bills that are already created thank you
thank you
seeing no further discussion unless the
clerk to call the role please
hb99 itl uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
collect votes yes representative
lasalles yes
representative Keller yes representative
Kelly yeah
representative Elwood yes representative
cocom yes
representative Cahill yes representative
stavis yes
representative Tatro
yeah representative Trey Levin
representative Gilman yes representative
majority yes representative mangaputi
yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes
representative priest yes and the
chairman yes motion passes uh 20-0
thank you Mr clerk uh any opposition to
this going on to the consent calendar
seeing none it will go on to the consent
calendar and HP 99 exec
uh reports I'm assuming representative
11 you'll be writing a committee report
your correction is assumed very good
thank you yes oh my gosh
very good
okay now we're gonna go ahead and uh
open up the executive hearing on
hb123 relative to governing bodies
governing body members of the budget
committee
and I believe we have a motion
representative
L Word
yes Mr chairman I'd like to make a
motion of ought to pass
thank you representative we have a
second representative power seconds
and representative Elwood would you like
to speak to your motion
well I really would Mr chairman because
this is the first time I've ever made a
motion of octopass
and this bill will clarify the role of
Municipal budget committee members
it will prohibit the governing body in
school board ex-officio members from
being counted towards uh the required
Quorum and from voting on matters before
the committee and it designates that
these
um
members will only serve in an in an
advisory capacity and I am very much in
favor of this bill
I feel that the budget committee must be
independent free from undue influence
anecdotally
my Town's elected or official budget
committee has a selectman who serves and
votes
and I feel that um this person is very
strong-willed
that we can't communicate directly with
the budget committee we have to funnel
all our information and inquiries
through the select board
and I just think that
um I'm agreeing with the phrase taking
two bites at the Apple
stacking the deck and that we need to
let our budget committee Members Own the
budget thank you
thank you representative microphone
thank you for their comment uh
representative 11. thank you Mr chair I
have a question for you my paperwork
says that this is proposed as OTP slash
a uh is there an amendment sir
we have we have it as OTP without an
amendment we were told that there might
be an amendment to correct a single word
but we do not have an amendment so it's
just OTP thank you for your answer
you're welcome
representative majori thank you Mr chair
I'm going to oppose the the OTP as
um I have been the select board
representative to the budget committee
I've chaired the budget committee I
still serve on the on the select board
when my select board finishes with its
budget we hand that budget to our
official budget committee it is no
longer the select board budget it is the
municipal but the official Municipal
budget committee budget same thing
happens with the school side they hand
their budget to the budget committee
it's the official school it's the
official Municipal budget committee
budget and the budget committee can make
any small change could make any
Draconian change they are certainly
within their rights to do that and I
feel that it is very important that the
the select board and School Board
representative to the budget committee
retain
their ability their full ability to vote
on whatever amendments happen and
whatever changes happen to that budget
to the extent that you're getting two
bites of the Apple everybody who serves
on a select board or budget committee
gets multiple bites of the Apple because
they vote on that budget then they go to
their election and they vote we're all
getting multiple bites of the Apple
we're doing it in the way that statute
provides and and I think that that is
it's critically important that you allow
people to retain their rights to make
decisions on multi-million dollar
Appropriations for each one of their
towns thank you Mr chair
thank you oops uh representative Kellogg
thank you
um I agree with the previous speaker
that currently it is allowed that they
can have multiple bites of the apple and
I agree with the sentiment that we
should remove that statutory right of
multiple bites at the Apple for the um
for the selectmin and and uh School
Board to
um try and influence the the will of the
budget committee
um I believe that they do once the
um makes in in my town at least once the
budget committee makes the changes the
the
Selectmen and the school boards both
have the opportunity to vote whether or
not they recommend that uh those changes
to the voters on the actual ballot and
it says three you know in my town
there's three Selectmen three Selectmen
don't uh recommend this these changes
and in on our ballot there um you know
there's uh this the budget the school uh
board is able to do that same uh
conveyance to the to the um
to the voters of the town to say we may
or may not agree with the rec uh the
changes that the budget committee made
and I uh think that it is a little bit
confusing to the budget to the voters to
see for example 3-0 and then a 5-2
um and not being aware that some of
those people are counted the same that
same person is counted twice in in those
numbers and so
um I think that there should they should
only be uh displayed once to the voters
that vote and so I will be voting in in
support of this motion thank you thank
you representative representative
Holland
so I'll State the obvious it's it's
always hard to pass a budget and I
always thought it would be easier but it
never is and so the most frustrating
part about uh working on a budget is
having people disagree with you
particularly when you think your idea is
better than theirs and so I think the
Temptation is to either ignore what
they're saying or even remove their
voice remove their votes so that it
makes it easier to get what I want and I
think that really harms the budget
process I think what the concerns that
were spoken to here actually are not
actually the statutory budget committee
composition it's the actual budget
process and I was the chair of a
advisory not a statutory and it's why I
was so obsessed with process I think you
mentioned really uh a good point was
that you had to funnel all your
information through one person and
therefore when you got to the really
really hard part of the budget that last
half a percent that really is
consequential it was really challenging
to make a decision and so therefore it's
really incumbent on the process to
include the statutory budget process uh
committee uh in the uh forming of the
budget and throughout the entire process
so that you have the information that
you need why did you set this budget
goal what are the priorities of your
budget what tools do you use to overcome
I mean I've heard the term cut but is it
like a deferred maintenance is it a
retired incentive am I shifting money
from one line to another I think there's
multiple changes that occur as it moves
either through the municipal side or the
school side and so it's really important
that the budget committee has seen all
those changes and understands the those
changes so that when the budget is
presented to you that you're able to
make the really difficult decisions and
so I think this really sets up sb2 towns
for some real Conflict at the
deliberative session because there the
voters will get they get two bites as
well right they get a chance at the
deliberative session to make changes
that you had and they get a chance to
vote on the budget and so I think having
a really coherent thought through
strategy as you approach the
deliberative session is really to the
advantage of municipality so I think
this is a bad idea and I oppose it
representative power
thank you Mr chairman I I would like to
bring the focus
um
of this bill you know back into the
center and it pertains to the powers of
elected officials and not so much a
budget process
and the powers of these elected fish
officials has to do with their ability
to vote so
voters in in a municipality they vote
for officials to be on a governing body
be it a select board or school board or
budget committee
and
um
there's a reason why a person cannot be
elected to both say for example a school
board and the budget committee
you can only be elected and sit on one
so I think that that should be the focus
and and therefore if voters elect
somebody to be on the governing body
I they should not have the the power and
the authority to vote both on the
governing body and and then also on a um
if they were appointed
they shouldn't then be able to vote on
the school board or the budget committee
and furthermore with regard to the
analogy getting two bytes of the Apple
that has to do with the position being
on being elected to a a position a
governing body position a school board
position and a budget committee position
when they get to vote again they're
they're functioning as a member of the
legislative body voting on The matters
before them in the warrant so I see that
as two different functions thank you
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair one thing I would
like to bring up is that on any board
committee or commission such as this
committee members speak in favor or
opposed to parts of the budget or the
total of the budget you know what what
they're looking at and it's possible
that a member of of a committee can
persuade one of those uh one of the
folks that were that this bill is trying
to exclude to change their mind about
what they've done or change their mind
you know on the school board budget
versus the um
uh Municipal budget so I think there's
an opportunity for
these members to retain uh their voting
status because there's an opportunity
for the discussion to be uh to change
and be persuadable and the other aspect
of this is that we often hear bills that
are
um
what's the word I want generated from a
problem in one town and we have seen
this bill before and we have seen the
same proponent come to us with the same
argument and to carry the Apple analogy
I would like to say that One Bad Apple
should not spoil the whole State's
Barrel
thank you
representative lasalles
to me this this bill should be called
the budget committee Independence bill
um
in in my town
the budget committee is held in very
high esteem
by the voters
so many times
the the people follow
the recommendation of the budget
committee uh a lot more than they do the
Selectmen or the school board
I'd like to reiterate what the vice
chairman said is that there's nothing to
keep me I'm going to look elected
select then I'm also an elected State
Rep I could be an elected School Board
member also
but I cannot
be if I'm any of those things I cannot
be an elected member of the budget
committee and I think that's
on purpose and I think it's uh a very
powerful tool
um so when the budget committee does
their deliberation on the town budget or
the School District budget
they need to have that Independence
to make their deliberations and come out
with their recommendation
that the townspeople can then get behind
having elected members
uh of the selectman and the school board
pollutes that Independence
and I feel I'm I'm
in support of this bill for that reason
and I'm going to make a lot of people
mad a lot of people that I respect are
disappointed in that but I I feel that
it's important that we maintain the
independence of the budget committee so
I will support this thank you
representative
representative uh majory
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
allowing me to speak again
um
I uh another huge issue that I have with
this we're talking about I my friend
from Litchfield who I have the most
respect for
um uh I hope so I do and you know that
you know that
um
this you're talking about the
independence
this bill completely neuters the role of
the select board the ex-officio member
on the budget committee by not even
allowing that person to count towards a
quorum so I'm not even sure if I were
that person elected to the or or
representing the budget committee I
wouldn't even go I wouldn't why would I
go I don't count towards a quorum and I
can't vote
so I'm not even sure what my influence
would be I would I would fight tooth and
nail and I think that would then be a
conflict I think this bill sets up more
conflict than it does but to the point
where I think it was representative
Hicks said a little while ago yes
um I think that the budget process
should be the most Co-op oh Helen I'm
sorry
I think the budget process should be
incredibly Cooperative but it is at
times adversarial and I and I absolutely
get that but I still can't support this
bill sorry representative thank you
representative representative lasalles
could you just hit your mic off there
thank you
okay seeing no more questions or
comments
bless the clerk to call the rule
okay it's hard to pass on House Bill one
two three representative power yes
representative Guthrie click votes yes
representative lasalles yes
representative Keller yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Elwood yes
representative corcom yes
representative Cahill
yes
Representative stavis no
representative Tatro
representative Trey Levin no
representative Gilman no
representative majority no
Representative no
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks no
representative Howland now
representative Priest No Mr chairman yes
10 to 10.
thank you Mr Clerk so where we're at
here there we can always
entertain another motion I believe we
know we're probably all for the Motions
are going to go so we can either
continue down that path or we can send
this to the
um
to the calendar
without recommendation
so are there any further motions Mr
chairman yes sir I make a motion that we
send it to the floor without
recommendation that I don't think that's
a motion that we entertain in this oh
buddy
the only point in my comment was I
believe if we start making other motions
we're going to end up the same place we
are and it'll eventually go to the floor
that way so do I hear any other motions
seeing none this will go to the floor
without recommendation uh representative
Elward you will write the committee
report
and representative Howland
thank you for that
and with that
hb123 uh yes HP 123 exact session is now
closed
open up House Bill 483 exec session duty
to remove uh to remove the duties of
County delegations and delegate them to
County Commissioners
um looking for a motion representative
Cahill
yes I would like to make a motion to itl
House Bill 483 to remove the duties of
the county delegations and give to
County Commissioners do I have a second
second represented
representative McDonald seconds
do we have any discussion
or the would you like to speak to your
motion yes I'd like to speak to my
motion yes this this bill seeks to give
away the legislative Branch's power
um and have almost no oversight for the
people
um and and I for that reason I vote
audio thank you representative
seeing no further discussion unless the
clerk to color roll
House Bill 483 itl
Vice chairman power yes representative
Guthrie
click votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Keller yes representative
Kelly
representative Elwood yes
representative cocom yes representative
Cahill
yes
representative stavis yes
representative Tatro yes representative
Trey 11 yes representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher
yes representative fix yes
representative howling yes
representative priest yes
Mr chairman yes motion passes 20-0
okay unanimous I assume there will be no
objection to this going on to the
consent calendar seeing none it will go
on to the consent calendar
and uh representative Cahill will write
the committee report
thank you uh we'll close the exact
session on 483 and open up exec session
HB 357 link the term for the belt
Belknap County officers
do I have a motion on that
representative yakella
I yes I make a motion to itl HB 357.
thank you representative seconded by
representative power representative
calorie do you like to speak yes
um I disagree with the idea that we
should have
um different uh term lengths for
different counties and
um in general I think that the uh that
there's no good reason for us to
continue down the path of of increasing
the terms from four years to to uh from
two years to four years I don't think
that they
um that the voters should have any less
oversight over these uh County officers
than they have over the governor or the
state reps or anyone else so for those
reasons I uh make the motion thank you
thank you representative as a further
comments questions
representative Gallagher
um so I would agree that
um
yes we should be uh
doing
that we should be treating the counties
the same but the last time we tried that
it got pulled from consent and then
stopped so
um
I think
that
um
that that just shows that a bill to
do
um
to change them all simultaneously
wouldn't really work so
um I think instead
we're just going to have to continue it
in this uh piecemeal way of trading
um each County separately and so I'll be
opposing the motion of Ito thank you
representative for the comments
representative power
thank you Mr chairman um I agree with
the concerns having a patchwork of terms
for County offices across the state and
additionally I have another concern with
regards to
um
people in the county
weighing in on this change from two-year
to four-year terms
my understanding through testimony
during the hearing is that the bill was
not brought up at a delegation meeting
it was only discussed with a few reps so
I have concern that the the Belknap
County delegation in fact did not
fully and sufficiently debate discuss
and weigh in on this significant change
thank you
thank you representative for the
comments
seeing that I'll make a quick one on
this one
um
to me this this comes down to
consistency I I was not here on this
committee last term
um I was aware of what happened on the
house floor
we can make the argument about precedent
being set but we We Know by uh Supreme
Court rulings of at the U.S and the
state level that sometimes those rulings
are found to have been made in bad bad
judgment and they've been overturned I
am personally not willing to continue
down a road as some of the other
speakers have talked talked about about
having patchwork
legislation in different counties
something like this I'm totally as
representative Kelly said uh two years I
believe should be the the where it
should remain and regardless of what
happened on the house floor yes uh last
year in Rockingham County
um it's my my thought process is that we
stop what happened last year and if uh
if the decision is made that four years
is okay for these uh individuals that
should apply to All Counties or it
should apply to none so in favor of the
itel motion
seeing no further comment could we have
the clerk call the roll
HP 357 itl
Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guthrie
collect votes yes representable Silas
yes
representative Keller yes
representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes
representative kokum yes
representative Cahill yes
Representative stavis no
representative Tatro
representative tree eleven no
representative Gilman no representative
majority no Representative no
representative Gallagher
no
representative Hicks no representative
Howland now
representative Priest No Mr chairman yes
vote is 10 to 10. okay so we find
ourselves in the exact same position as
we did a couple couple bills ago
um I'm gonna say the same thing I said
there we could make other motions or we
could simply allow this to go
to the calendar as a
without recommendation so are there any
other motions
seeing none this will go on the calendar
without recommendation representative
yokella I assume we'll
right for us and for
anybody on the minority side gonna write
a report I got
representative majority
and with that we close the exact session
on 357 opened up the exact session on HP
312 uh relative to petitions for Warrant
articles at a special meeting
and I believe you representative yo
Kelly you have a motion yes I make a
motion to itl
sorry representative uh is there a
second on that motion I second the
motion
representative lasalles represents sex
and some motion
hey
go ahead
um I believe we are also had an
amendment on this bill
that that might be true but uh number
we're on the motion of itl right now so
okay
uh with the representative of your
calorie like to speak yes I think that
um
as someone that has done many petition
Warren articles in my local uh Community
I think that it is
um
a great opportunity to
empower the local citizenry and I think
that exp raising the uh requirement to
um to the amount suggested in this bill
is
um onerous on that
um engagement and those discussions and
um one of the things that just came up
at my local
um
budget committee was a discussion about
um the
uh uh for the school budget the contract
that
um is proposed for our collective
bargaining agreement and if that
contract was to fail
um and the Warren article saying hey can
we call a special meeting was also to
fail
then the town would have to go to court
and and require and get a judge to grant
them an emergency which would take
some time whereas Gathering up 25
signatures to
call a special meeting on that topic
could be done potentially in the same
day
um and so I think that it in that
situation it would be very valuable to
be able to have a low bar and it would
save the taxpayers
um having to go time and money having to
go to court to try and get an emergency
or to gather the thousands potentially
thousands of signatures that would be
necessary to call a special meeting
under this new proposed Rule and so for
those and and many more reasons I I make
the motion to itl thank you thank you
representative Gallagher uh may I ask a
question of Representative yokawa
you can always ask there's no
requirement to answer but go ahead okay
so you said um
specifically
that the number in this bill would be an
onerous requirement is there
um a different number that you would
consider not onerous
thank you for the question I think let's
say 30 people I'm I'm okay with that
thank you representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair
thank you colleagues for hearing what I
have to say I think that this bill would
make it harder for the people to
participate in their government and I
think we should be seeking to make it
easier for the people to participate in
government
so
for that reason I vote to itl
thank you representative representative
tatra
thank you Mr chair
um
my opinion I guess takes a little bit
different path
um this is going to cause
hardship on parts of
the uh
an sb2 town
where you have to have a second election
which means you have to have
the
all the same workers that you had for
the regular election so it's going to
cost double
what the town
has without any
help from the state
does this
I don't think this
I believe this falls under unfunded
unfunded mandate in my my eyes
that's it
representative power
thank you Mr chairman I support the
motion of itl I have a number of
concerns with with the bill as written
the first would be
um
it strikes language that has a provision
for municipalities with that that are
perhaps deemed smaller and it specifies
for towns with less than ten thousand
inhabitants that there's the requirement
of 50
um or more signatures of Voters or a
quarter of the voters in town whichever
is fewer and this bill has written just
completely strikes that and
um Additionally the provision was that
if you have a municipality with 10 000
or more the the required signature
threshold was five percent of of the
voters and
um
making this the the threshold the same
for small towns and larger towns to me
is not fair and there was wisdom in in
having this distinction in the the
statute that is currently on the books
and additionally during the hearing um
I asked about the changing the threshold
to to 10 percent
um
and the answer that I got that it was
just completely random it's just
something that OLS decided to draft into
the bill and so there was no real
rationale for
um
for for that change so I support the
motion of itl thank you representative
representative majority
chair
um
the a special meeting we all know there
has to be some some cause for that
special meeting and I respect the
process of getting to that cause if you
have a concern with your local
government you should be able to to
voice that concern especially if you
think there's some impropriety but there
there is a lot of weight then given to
that which which imposes to the
taxpayers great additional costs one
Community next to mine upwards of thirty
thousand dollars for the special for
that special meeting uh the intent of
the bill is to is to apply the same
weight of that application to hopefully
what the intent of of the special
election would be and I and I might
hypothesize here that if it this vote
were to get to 1010 there may be another
motion to uh to offer something that
might help if we can get to if there is
a 10 10 vote but I'm only hypothesizing
thank you Mr chair thank you
for their comments represent Manchester
Beauty thank you uh Mr chair
um my comment is I'm not in a town but
this
increases the threshold to ask for a
special election a special meeting
by engaging if we are not able to get
five percent or a higher threshold then
there is that opportunity to engage with
the voters of that town to bring them
why this is needed if they're not able
to there's another threshold to save the
Democratic process well we didn't get
five percent so whatever the voters
decided States so this would be another
way of increasing the engagement of the
voters in that Community to participate
in the Democratic process which we pride
so much in our state thank you
for the comments representative Davis
thank you Mr chair
um I would like to um second the
comments of my colleague representative
Maggiore
and say that if if we are split truly
split down the middle on this vote that
we um we might make another motion to
consider the amendment which was duly
submitted to this committee
for the comments
seeing none I'll make one comment on
this regardless of the uh the original
bill or the
um what might be considered a potential
Amendment the
the issue here I'm going to pick up on a
comment made by representative Gilman a
little earlier and it this this appears
to be
a solution that was brought on by it's a
single Town issue all our everybody who
testified as far as I recall
was from the
beautiful town of Greenland I understand
I grew up around there however
um
I do see this as a single Town issue
nobody else weighed in on it no for or
against so I I'm I'm more than happy to
let it continue the way it is so I I
will be voting
um in favor of the itl thank you
see no further comments uh clerk color
a house bill 312 uh itl
Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guthrie
clerk votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Ocala
yes representative Kelly yeah
representative Elwood yes
representative Holcomb
yes
representative Cahill yes
Representative stavis no
representative titro
yes
representative tree 11. no
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yeah oops yes
oh did you get that I know I'm just
oh wait you're right no I was wondering
Mr clerk never correct okay
tell me what I'm supposed to do what
one more time Mr majority is that a no
that is a no thank you
Representative no
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks no representative
Howland now
representative priests no
Mr chairman yes motion passes 11 to 10.
thank you Mr Clark uh motion about uh
I'm sorry motion uh itl uh
representative yokella be writing the
committee report I assume there will be
a Minority Report yes sir I'll take care
of that representative majority
what am I supposed to do Mr Clark sure
thank you
okay
um we've been at it for a little while
let's just take about a 10 minute break
be back at uh about five minutes five
minutes to the hour please
I hear it all broken down yes no where
it was going to go and then that threw
me
everybody is returned
foreign
okay open up the executive session on HB
293 allowing town to appropriate funds
to create
oh I'm sorry we're on 403.
sorry about that uh relative to the
authority of Selectmen or assessors to
Abate taxes and I believe we have a
motion representative lasalles
yes Mr chairman I uh make up I move
Amendment
um
zero one five five h
uh thank you is there a second
I second that representative power
and representative would you like to
speak to the amendment
yes uh does the committee have a copy of
of the amendment
um
zero one five five h
D okay
just to uh
refresh everyone's memory the whole
purpose of this and it's it's
written kind of convoluted but is to
make it
um
easier to correct
inadvertent uh errors that occur and it
it the whole purpose is is to make it
reasonable for the Selectmen to make
corrections as necessary
thank you uh representative
just to clarify
so this says it replacing entirety
following the on the bill can you please
allude to where it starts
I'm not sure what uh the amendment zero
one five five H amend the bill by
replacing all after the enacting Clause
with the following
so it looks like
it's replacing the entire bill
is that correct that would be my
interpretation representative
representative yukela
thank you
um
so this amendment has the same problem
that the original bill has that
um
uh good cause is all of these reasons
that are are listed are within good
cause and so it is actually not making
anything easier it's making things that
um would be considered good cause but
don't follow under these delimited lists
no longer to be adjusted and so for uh I
don't see
that there is a real value in
hamstringing the Selectmen to make other
uh
Corrections that previously had shown
good cause and now
um wouldn't fall under this list so
um I do not support this this amendment
or this bill as as proposed thank you
what's up
Calico
um
you might want to wait for this yeah
representative 11.
your chair
um may I ask a question of the
motion motioner
I will say you may ask that question
there's no requirement to answer but yes
of course I got you thank you
representative lasalles can you give me
an idea as to why the phrase good cause
shown has been removed and replaced with
these detailed commentary
yes to my colleague I I would say that
and it's it's not my bill but I I would
say it's just to delineate
the
causes
and it it's meant to be more restrictive
rather than just throwing the whole uh
the whole door wide open it's to be more
restrictive but again it's not my bill
but that's that's how I read it
follow up yes well
another question give me another
question oh okay go ahead
um it's my understanding that good cause
or good cause shown is a legal term is
that your understanding as well
I'm not a lawyer so I I don't know
for the discussion
representative Gallagher
um
so I just want to
um get some things straight about
whether this is the um
about whether things we're discussing
are in the underlying bill or the
amendment um so
I see good cause
being removed in both the original bill
and the amendment so
I would
oppose this bill
as written and also oppose this bill
as amended but then the question of
whether to amend it
is still a separate one I think
there could be a case
to um
may be made
um
for the amendment and that it makes a
bad Bill slightly better
um
but I'm still not really quite sure
whether
it's worth amending something that I'm
going to vote against anyway so
um I am
uh I I would appreciate it if anyone
else who is having
um the same uncertainty could share
their thoughts
representative Elwood
thank you Mr chairman I've always
believed that no bill is better than a
bad Bill thank you
representative
Mr chair uh in a city that will remain
unnamed
um
the housing appeals board issued a
ruling
that used the term good cause
um against the planning board and said
unnamed City
uh we were at first outraged by this but
then when we did a little bit more
digging and a little bit more research
and speaking with lawyers we came to
understand that the term good cause is a
recognized legal phrase that is used
with a very common understanding by the
courts
so I opposed this bill based on its
striking the the legal term good cause
from the language
brother excuse me further comments
I'll make one that might help answer
um representative 11's
question uh good cause shown sure it can
be used as a legal term the sponsor
brought forth this bill um based on
situations that had been occurring in
his his town but this is not a single
Town issue
um he also sent along at three or four
court cases in New Hampshire that dealt
with
this good cause shown being abused
um the one if anybody took the time to
read it it was very enlightening and
eye-opening and some of the comments the
the decision I wish I had wrote them
down written them down I could have uh
given them to you right here but
basically you had
individuals in a city to the North Way
North
who use that clause
where
the
selectman in the town
along
gave themselves abatements on their own
properties along with another individual
and friend in the town
that is and they claimed the use of the
term good cause shown
it was uh they were reprimanded mightily
in the court decision and
so that was overturned there was another
uh incident down in Siebert not to the
level of egregiousness but very similar
this bill I I believe is actually very
good the Selectmen and assessors
are limited by the administrative of
clerical errors which of course or an
assessment or evaluation error of course
and there was a concern that they
wouldn't be able to
give a an abatement based on poverty
that was added in in this final
Amendment
so I I'm
when I first saw the bill being new to
the committee when I saw the word good
cause shown in that that
just made the hair on the back of my
next stick up thinking holy cow that's
just a an opportunity for abuse
um
so I'm fully supported of the amendment
uh zero one one zero one five five H
thank you
representative management
thank you uh Mr chair I have a question
in terms of we are looking at one
Amendment but the sponsor Prime sponsor
brought two together so what was the
you know I know we are talking about
Amendment one zero one five five and
um
is there any explanation to why there
were two but we are picking one
if that's a question to me I'll say that
the representative Manchester you have
the opportunity to look through and see
what the differences is and if you have
questions ask the you know the original
sponsor representative Smith um I
it would appear to me that they he
further clarified his first amendment by
improving on the second amendment that
would be my interpretation
for the comments
uh C9 could I have the clerk call the
roll please
HB 403 the adopt the amendment of zero
one five five h
uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
clerk votes yes
representative lasalles yes
representative Keller
no
representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes
representative corkum yes
representative Cahill yes
yes Representative stavis no
representative Tatro no
representative Trey Levin no
representative Gilman no
representative majority no
Representative mangaputi no
representative Gallagher
no
representative Hicks no representative
Howland now
representative Priest No
and Mr chairman yes
uh motion fails nine to eleven is there
for the motion
representative majority
yeah I would move uh itl on
one second uh representative stavis
seconds would you like to speak further
on this
um
sorry thank you Mr chair
um and not to uh not to speak too much
about it but good cause is a legal term
that has legal standing
um I I think to further delineate
without uh adding terms like not limited
to or uh including but not limited to
hamstrings uh the select board in the
town and may uh I I think may cause
farther problems so for those reasons I
support the itl thank you thank you
further comments representative Kellum
thank you
um
I think that what we're talking about
here is
um
reducing taxes
on on people and if there's uh
if if abuse happens as the chair
brought up
um I think that those people should be
um not re-elected
um and I think that
um
however
uh I so I I don't agree that that you
know you should be voting yourself an
abatement
um however I think that if the if
someone comes to the
to this uh Selectmen and and
believe and are able to convince the
selectman that this is
um uh appropriate that they should pay
less taxes then I don't think that the
that the state should come in the way
and say no you you need to pay more
taxes so
um for that reason I think that
um
error on the side of being more General
allows people to pay less taxes and I'm
all for that so thank you thank you
representative
seeing no more discussion uh click call
the role please
uh HB 403 itl uh Vice Chairman's power
no
representative Guthrie
vement is it
clerk votes yes
representative lasalles
no
no just need a second here
did you mean to vote Yes
yes
[Laughter]
you're always support me
Mr clerk would you do should we commence
the vote again why don't we start from
the top
I appreciate everyone understanding okay
the motion is to itl HB 403
Vice chairman power no
representative Guthrie
collect votes no
representative Silas no
representative yokella yes
representative Kelly
representative Elwood no
Representative kolkum no
representative Cahill
Representatives Davis yes
representative Tatro yes
yes representative tree 11 yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priests yes
Mr chairman
no
uh 12 to 8.
thank you uh
that will go on the calendar the
majority uh majority opinion report will
be written by
representative
okay
and representative turcott will write it
or the committee report for the minority
on the vote
and with that America um HP 403
executive session is closed we will move
on to House Bill
293 allowing town to appropriate funds
to create a town scholarship fund I
believe we have a motion representative
power thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
make a motion on House Bill 293 in
expedient to legislate do we have a
second
who said second
representative Tatro seconds
is there any discussion
represent power
thank you Mr chairman um the way that I
see this is
um a scholarship is not an essential
function of local government
it's can be considered a want and and
not a need and therefore the raising and
appropriating of taxpayer dollars
to fund a scholarship
to me is is inappropriate
there are other ways for a municipality
to offer scholarships
doing this at the Town level through
taxpayer dollars to me is is not a good
idea
and
additionally in the hearing there were
some concerns with regards to the
mechanics of of how this this would
actually work
and
I I was going to make one more point but
I don't remember what that was so
thank you further discussion
see representative priests I will also
be voting to itl this because I don't
think
that it is
the town's responsibilities to do a
scholarship
if they want to create a fund and have
it public donations that would be great
but I don't think public money should be
doing this
thank you
for the discussion representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair
I also find problems with this bill uh
what are the questions that was not
answered or could not be answered by the
um
the sponsor was how this would work with
education Freedom accounts and would
would families have a chance to have two
bites at the Apple
get and get funds from both from both
opportunities
representative power
thank you Mr chairman what I was going
to say is there are other ways if
citizens want to
establish a scholarship fund there are
other ways to do it
and that that it should be done
with private donations and not taxpayer
dollars that was the point I forgot
representative
thank you Mr chair
um
we were undecided about this bill when
we discussed it but in hindsight and
looking further at the wording of Bill I
now
uh am in favor of the itl motion I feel
that the word scholarship is over broad
what what would these scholarships be
for what would they fund there's no
definition there's no mechanism for
means testing so how could you be sure
that the people who wanted the
scholarships truly needed the
scholarships and it just doesn't seem
like a good use of taxpayer money to me
so I will be voting in support of the
itl motion
foreign
Hicks
thank you Mr chair
um I like the idea of this bill but I
agree with my colleagues
that it is too broad the language and
really the voters should be deciding
what to do their tax dollars so I'll be
voting to support the Ito
further discussion representative
schlevin
Mike thank you Mr chair my comment would
be similar to representative stavis at
first I was in favor and then as I read
more I became uninfavor
specifically because there was no
mechanism that said who gets to pick who
gets the scholarship and who gets to
pick
what kind of scholarship is created and
I agree with my colleague who stated
that there are other ways several of my
colleagues that a town can create a
scholarship in the name of someone or in
honor of a family or for any number of
reasons and it could be managed by the
town quote unquote as a pass-through
without the town using tax dollars to to
do that so I will be voting itl thank
you
representative men's Purdy
thank you Mr chair
um I too will be supporting the itl
motion in my city we have an Education
Foundation
established which is scholarship used
for both the
um by private donations and fundraising
and that would be used both for the
students as well as for the teachers to
provide supplies in public schools this
is to augment the public school teachers
in the public school kids and
and that's not doing with taxpayer money
and in this case taking the taxpayer
money
and putting it in a pot and who decides
who gets it just doesn't seem fair and
so I will be voting in support of Ito
thank you
representative Gallagher
um so
I'd just like to start by saying um I
support
um
municipalities being able to pay for
education in general I believe that
education is a public good that everyone
benefits from so um
it
um I I I
um
I I do think that
it can it does often make sense for
taxpayers to pay for education I just
think in this case
since the wording isn't clear enough
since
scholarship isn't defined and
they didn't say
uh the Bill's sponsors
didn't say what type of schooling
specifically
uh scholarship funds could be used for
um yeah I I just think that the
implementation isn't uh isn't good
enough so
um
I will be joining the vote to itl
anybody else
like to speak
on an ital
y seeing none would I ask the clerk to
call the roll please
HB 293 itl Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Keller
yes representative Kelly
uh representative Valwood yes
representative colcom yes representative
Cahill yeah represents Davis yes
representative Tatro yes
representative tree 11th yes
representative Gilman yes represent
majority
yes representative yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes and Mr
chairman yes
twenty to zero
well that objection this will go on the
consent calendar
I see no objections and we will close
the hearing uh the exact session on 293
um don't move yet we are going to take a
lunch break till 1 30.
next week just so you know the decision
was made
on Wednesday we will be
doing 18 exec bills I would ask you to
each go back and review what just
occurred on that last
vote
there were a number of people that spoke
itl there was nobody that spoke in favor
of it if we are to complete our work
next week
um
we may not want to have
10 individuals making the same statement
when it's a foregone conclusion just an
observation we'll see everybody back at
1 30. there's a housing caucus lunch in
the in the legislative
cafeteria oh okay just in case anyone
wants to go
folks we're going to get going
representative stavis and I have
discussed the issue we have a photo of
Representative yokella introducing a
bill so what we are going to do is uh go
to the last four bills
um and then come back the last four
bills
we believe we're pretty much in
agreement on so we're going to go to
those
and then we'll come back so we're going
to open up the exact session on House
Bill 203 relative to a public annual
County budget
Mr chair yes sir I would like to move
Amendment zero three five eight H to
house bill 203.
thank you okay uh representative uh
lasalles makes the motion and seconded
by the clerk
would you like to speak to it sir
um
first of all does everybody have a copy
of that Amendment
um
it's pretty self-explanatory it's to the
purpose of the bill and the amendment is
to make the distribution of the county
budgets the delivery and distribution of
that a lot more up to date so that they
can do it a lot more efficiently
thank you is there any further
discussion representative
um
thank you Mr chair uh representative
lasalles it is the delivery that's uh
electronic wasn't that one of the
conversation
uh
any means of
delivery
a representative acceptable right are
you requesting to ask a question of
Representative lasalles yes yes uh
repsilence lasalles I'll answer that the
question
um
they mailed or delivered we've spoken
about this a couple times now the mail
they're delivered in the second half of
the bill
was put in there under that's under the
Hillsborough and Rockingham County
budget notice a budget meeting is there
to match the existing language
that exists in the in the top one where
it says mail their delivery it's or
delivered it's simply uh an attempt to
match up and sync the language that's
all that is so one follow-up Mr tip
sorry a question or a statement
um a question so does that clarify all
the debates he had
the delivery is
in whatever means it is delivered to the
person
it is mailed or delivered okay
for the questions comments seeing none
will call a roll on Amendment uh two
zero two three zero three five h
uh adopt Amendment uh Vice chairman
power yes representative Guthrie yeah
yeah clerk votes yes representative
Visalus yes
representative Kelly
yes
uh represent I would
corruptive
call come call come yes yes thank you
representative Cahill yes representative
stavis yes representative Tatro yeah
representative Trey 11 yes
representative Gilman
representative majority yes
representative mangaputi yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative priest yes Mr
chairman yes 19-0
thank you Miss clerk do I have a
following motion
representative lasalles yes Mr chairman
I'd like to move
ought to pass as amended on HB 203
seconded by representative McDonald's
would you further like to speak to it
no any questions or comments
on the bill as amended
seeing none will ask the clerk to call
the roll
uh otpa on Bill number 203 for sharing
power yes representative custody yeah
click folks yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Kelly yeah representative
Elwood yes representative colcom yes
Brothers of Cahill
yeah represents Davis yes representative
yeah
yeah representative 11. yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majority yes representative yes
representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes Mr chairman
yes
motion passes 19-0
thank you Mr clerk without objection
this will go on the consent calendar
and the committee report representative
lasalles will be writing that thank you
we'll close the hearing on HB 203 oh or
the exec session on 203 we'll open up
the executive session on HP 226 enabling
municipalities to regulate single-use
containers and I believe Representatives
Davis has a motion
thank you Mr chair I moved to itdl HB
and I'd like to speak to my motion and
uh somebody like the second second
representative majority seconds uh
representative thank you Mr chair having
been on the municipal and County
government committee for several years
now I've seen many bills
um similar to this one come before us
uh there's there can be no doubt that
plastic waste is a problem in New
Hampshire and in the world
um in many states and many countries are
moving to reduce uh plastic waste but in
we have not yet seen a bill come before
this committee
that adequately defines single use point
of sale single-use plastic bag we find
that this bill is
um not specific enough to provide
guidance for retailers or customers and
could have unintended consequences and
therefore recommend itl thank you thank
you for the discussion representative
priest
thank you Mr chairman I am for this bill
and against it Elling it uh if there's
such a thing
um because I think we've
we've reached a point
in New Hampshire
where we are being our environment our
Parks our Lakes our oceans are being
clogged and choked by the single-use
plastic
and Retail isn't taking the
responsibilities the production isn't
taking any responsibilities the state
isn't taking any responsibilities so
it's really up to the localities to do
this and this enables them to do this
and this is the first step that I think
can address the problem
that is really degrading our environment
thank you
thank you representative for the
comments representative Holland we'll go
right down the line
so uh this pains me to support the itl
because I've spent the last five years
on our town Solid Waste committee
um and you know when I look at the
problem it's not just the plastic bag
it's everything that you stick in it and
so uh the packaging is complex enough
that consumers are often like looking at
something and they're saying is this
recyclable is this not recyclable which
leads to recycling you throw it in the
recycling bin and hope for the best and
so while I think something needs to be
done with packaging I don't think this
bill would allow us to do that and I
think it's sufficiently vague that it
adds problems to retailers so
unfortunately I have to support the IDL
representative Hicks
I agree with everything that represents
Davis said
um I will be opposing the itl just
because I want to make sure that there
are enough votes against the itl that
people don't assume that nobody supports
further conserving Plastics
thank you representative representative
Gala
um so
yeah I'm going to be
opposing the itl motion
um just because this well not not so
much this term but last terms version of
this bill was one of the most popular
bills in my inbox for constituents to
um emailed me about
um a lot of my constituents care deeply
about the environment and want to see
single-use Plastics
um regulated ass
um a way of helping to preserve our
environment
um
one thing I will
um bring up the
um that
a concern that I don't
think has been addressed is um
so I I'm also trying to be
um very
sensitive to the needs of the disability
Community as well and
um
the disability Community often has
interesting perspectives on single-use
Plastics
like apparently some disabled people
actually need them so um
yeah I think that would be
um
if this bill comes back in the future I
that would be a perspective
I'd want to
hear from
in the future but for now I'm just going
to be voting
against the itl motion
for the comments representative
benchputi
thank you Mr chair I strongly oppose itl
for a couple of reasons one is
it's well established that single-use
plastic
plastic especially plastic bag has
caused a lot of havoc in a lot of
different communities
and because as much as we you know we
heard
how much just 10 percent
of the bags produced or recycled and
others might be reused
reused yet it ends up after three uses
four uses it ends up in the landfill it
has no place else to go
so reuse does not mitigate
production in the first place so if we
have to take anything seriously to make
sure we leave this planet
better for my grandson in his next
Generation his
uh great grand my great grandkids we
have to start now we have come to this
point in you know and I strongly feel
that addressing recycle as well as
production generation both angles we
have to take only then we can make a
small dent in what's where we are with
this so with that I would this would be
a step in the right direction
so I strongly support this bill and I
will be voting against ITF
it representative colcom
I will be supporting itl on this bill
well I agree that we do have an issue
with how we handle our plastic waste I
um I disagree that the single-use bags
are our problem to address when I walk
into the grocery store and I can walk
through the produce aisle and pick up
potatoes apples and any other vegetable
that's in a plastic bag and then move
into the deli department and receive my
cut meats and cheeses in a plastic bag
and my prepared salads in a plastic
container and then move over to the fish
department and I get my fish packaged in
a plastic bag those are all single-use
bags I'm never going to reuse a bag that
comes from a piece of fish and then I
move into the meat department and what's
everything pot wrapped in the meat
department plastic and I can also walk
over to the aisle that sells everything
plastic I can buy plastic bags plastic
wrap plastic containers all in a single
aisle I can buy plastic but when I leave
the store I'm now being told that I
can't take plastic bag
so because we're going to ban that or
we're going to address that I just think
that this is addressing the wrong issue
and that there are many other single
plastic items that should be addressed
thank you representative for the
comments representative Gilman thank you
Mr chair
um I will probably vote in support of
the itl and the reason is because there
is a Senate bill that changes the method
of doing this and it's to allow or
the Department of Environmental Services
to use their rule making Authority
excuse me rule making authority to um
make make uh not decisions but uh the
way forward I guess and and how to
define how to um how do you what happens
in the landfills and those those kind of
issues that were were worried about
um so I think that's maybe actually a
better way to move forward thank you
for the comments
seeing none will ask the clerk to call a
roll
HB 226 itl Vice chairman power yes
represents Guthrie click folks yes
representative lasalles yes
represent your Keller yes representative
Kelly
representative Elwood yes
representative uh corcum yes
representative Cahill yes represents
Davis yes
representative Tetro yes
representative Trey Levin yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majority
yes representative Mega pootie no
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks no
representative Howland a pain DS
representative Priest No
Mr chairman yes
motion passes 16-4
is there a objection to the consent
calendar on this bill
yes
okay I S here yes so it will go on the
regular calendar uh representative
stavis will you be writing the committee
report on this yes
and for the minority opinion who will be
writing that committee report
representative priests okay
okay that closes the hearing on HB
226 executive session I'm sorry
we'll now open the executive session on
HB 237 relative to the date of asset
evaluation and looking for a motion from
representative majority
thank you Mr chair I'd like to move
ought to pass on House Bill 237.
is there a second
representative power
seconds
and would you like to speak to your
motion representative majority thank you
Mr chair uh yes I would like to speak to
the motion representative power has
presented a bill
that is that clarifies a bit of the
statute right now and that clarifies
this try it again clarifies the existing
statute and I think we'll make it easier
and more efficient for communities to
operate and therefore I hope everyone
can support the ought to pass
foreign
thank you very much is there any further
comment
seeing none we'll ask the clerk to color
roll
uh HP 237 OTP Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
collect votes yes represent Salas
yes
representative yes representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes representative
carlcam yes representative Cahill
opens Davis yes
representative Tatro
representative Trey Levin yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majority
yes
representative yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative preach yes
Mr chairman yes
motion passes 20 to zero
without objection consent calendar
seeing no objections it'll be on this
consent that closes the exec session to
HB 237
we'll open up the exact session on House
Bill 273 requiring composting and waste
recycling to be made available to
residents
and do I have a motion
yeah
that's almost ideal
um I would like to move to retain this
bill
okay is there a second
uh motion to retain
uh is made by representative Gallagher
Gallagher seconded by representative
Howland and would you like to speak to
your motion
uh sure so yeah
um
this is a bill
um from last term that um
so yeah I live in public housing and
um one of the
things about it is that
we don't have any
um
any recycling or compost facilities
available to us in it so last year or
last term I had introduced a bill to
um
make those available
we referred it to interim study but then
never actually did the study so
um this term
um
I had meant to turn it into a study
committee
but uh OLS didn't
draft it that way they just gave the old
language again so the motion to retain
is to
um
give me time to get the bill
re-drafted
um
so that way I can get to do what I
actually want it to do
um
so and
so some things I've found out by the way
since last term on this topic um
are
so one
um
one of the things that's an issue here
is the city of Concord has a pass you
throw program where
um
where
to have your trash collected by the
municipal trash pickup Services
um you have to use these special purple
bags
um so some
some landlords some um
or some buildings
or groups of people in buildings we're
trying to get around that by just
putting their uh
trash in the recycling which was
increasing the uh
spoilage
rate
um
and so I talked with somebody from our
Waste Services and
um
they said
that yeah the spoilage rate from just
having it collected directly from the
buildings is generally too high in that
the best way to um
go about it instead would be to make it
more possible for
um
people to uh bring their recycling
directly to the transfer station
themselves so
another
Avenue I might be pursuing would be to
um
have this
uh to turn the bill or into
a wage who
require that uh
public transit services
provide
transit to
transfer stations but yeah that's just
one of the options that a study
committee could consider so yeah I ask
that we can retain uh this bill so that
um we can have the time to figure that
out
thank you so further discussion
representative manager a quick question
to
the client sponsor
um I
if I understand the intention is to
bring composting to public housing
there's another we talked about another
bill that has passed
composting being food waste being
diverted from
landfill HB 300 which passed
environmental and agricultural committee
20 to nothing
were considering that that bill is for
all food waste
would that help address it doesn't make
a distinction whether it's public
housing or single family or apartment
complex so would that make it easier
to kind of focus on that than retaining
and working on one just one small piece
just a question
um yeah I do think that bill would be
helpful too
um
uh
I
I mean yeah I guess if it passed you yes
Lily it's probably going to pass as well
but I still think
it might be worthwhile to wait and see
what happens with it just in case
there's something
unusual occurs and if it does pass then
after the bill comes back from retention
we can just ital it then but if it
doesn't if leather build doesn't pass
then we can have this in backup
to um do further work with
further comments or questions
representative Holland
so unlike the plastic bag one the solid
waste is about 30 percent uh a food
waste is about 30 percent of our solid
waste and the real challenges are not
limited to public housing it's like how
do you have a collection system in your
community and then the second problem is
if it includes any dairy or meat there's
very few processing centers you can't
just throw it in a in any place you
really need a specialized processing
place to actually take take it to and
we've been working for five years and
trying to work on more of a regional
approach that we can bring the compost
easily to it's not a long transportation
and the real benefit of this is over the
last two years or three years there's
been extreme volatility in the recycling
markets and there's been a real
tightening in the contamination markets
which has led to real flux uh real uh
fluctuations in our Sanitation in budget
and so composting especially if you can
do it locally offers us an opportunity
to stabilize our Solid Waste costs and
so if a system can be brought together
that really helps us in terms of how do
we do a pickup and then where do we
bring it if that could be part of this
it would be very beneficial
for the comments
I'll just make one based on the
representative Holland's comment I would
remind us that this bill specifically
speaks towards composting and recycling
for public housing residents
see no further questions uh we'll call
Heather clerkalore
hbi 273 the motion is to retain the bill
uh Vice chairman of power no
representative Guthrie
click votes no
weapons for Silas no
uh Representative yokella no
representative Kelly
representative Elwood no
Representative colcom no
representative Cahill
versus Davis no
representative Tatro
representative Trey Levin yeah
yeah representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative Mega putty
yes
representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks no
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes
Mr chairman no
motion fields 13-7
thank you Mr clerk do we have another
motion on the table representative power
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to move
an expedient to legislate on House Bill
273. do we have a second I'll second
that
representative Hicks seconds that
further discussion
uh represent powered like to speak thank
you Mr chairman so um
we did have this this
same similar Bill last year in committee
and
um
now we we have it again
and I see it as an unfunded mandate
because clearly
um
to require that public housing provide
on-site composting and recycling will be
in an added cost
I have a family member that lives in an
apartment in Manchester and they
unfortunately don't provide recycling at
that apartment complex because it does
cost extra money to have those
receptacles
on site
additionally I see other problems with
with the bill as written with regard to
the um provisions of on-site composting
um specifically there's safety issues
with um
that attracting pests in vermin
additionally I would say that
not all activities are feasible in
apartment complexes
um
and and and this would be on-site
composting and recycling
um
to provide that that ability to do that
on site
um
for it it it's it poses difficulties and
the last point that that I would make is
that not all municipalities have the
ability at this point in time to collect
compost New Hampshire as I understand it
just simply does not have that
infrastructure at the time at this point
in time and therefore the bill
um to me just would not work as written
thank you representative further
discussion
representative Gallagher
um I'd just like to say I'm okay with
the motion of itl and um yeah don't
think we need to have any further
discussion on it so that's all thank you
for that representative for the
discussion seeing none we'll have the
clerk call the roll
HP 273 itl
um Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
collect folks yes representative Los
Alice yes
uh representative Keller yes
representative Kelly
representative of Elwood yes
representative corcom yes
representative Cahill
Brothers Davis yes representative yeah
yeah representative a reluctant yes
representative Gilman yes represent
majority yes
representative yes representative
Gallagher uh yes
representative Hicks yes Corruption of
howling yes representative priest yes
and Mr chairman yes motion passes 20-0
thank you Mr Clark uh objections to the
consent calendar
seeing none it'll be on the consent
calendar that closes the exact session
on hb273
report uh representative power
so that leaves us with one last bill
we'll open up the exact session on hb90
relative to Municipal planning master
plan
and do we have a motion representative
yes I'd like to make a motion to itl
House Bill 90. there was a few concerns
we have a motion for an experience to
legislate by representative Cahill
seconded by representative Kelly
representative Cahill would you like to
speak to your emotion
yes thank you Mr chair sorry about that
there was some concerns with this bill
having some language that opened it up
to uh
uh free free range cart carte blanche
here
um
with regards to lines nine through
eleven
and uh for that reason
I make a motion to itl
thank you representative for their
discussion representative stavis
thank you Mr chair
um I think as everybody probably knows
municipality Master plans are
guideposts they're not not anything
about them that says shall it's just a
kind of a map guiding the way
and we have found in our community that
our Master planning process is simply
not able to keep up with the times
because times are changing so quickly
and we felt I worked on this bill with
our planning director and we felt that
it was time for the statute to reflect
the fact that the times are changing
quickly and that residents have new and
different needs of their municipalities
these days than they did
12 years ago which was probably when
some master plans began their process
and we thought that this would help
bring us into the 20th and dare I say
the 21st century
so um
for that reason I hope you will vote
against the Ito I will be voting against
the itl thank you thank you
representative for the comment
a representative Parr thank you Mr
chairman
um I'll be supporting the the motion of
itl and I I did speak to a planning
board member in in my municipality and
it was explained to me that um
what the bill is intending to do can
already in fact be done and I I was a
referenced to the section of Statute
which would be come under RSA 674 colon
2 n where it discusses
um energy is is covered and therefore in
my mind the the bill is not needed
thank you representative representative
of uh Holland
thank you Mr chair
um while actually again in the master
plan there's only two sections that you
have to approve the first is the vision
statement and the second is the land use
statement and then as Representative
Steve has said there have been added
suggestions that you could do these
things and put them on and while the
energy section is in there there's a
broad section on energy this bill
actually does provide more flexibility
in the planning board for those of us
who have eight-year-old Master plans
right now our planning board really has
become a reacting board and this gives
us more flexibility as we rewrite our
master plan to begin to put those in
rather than having to come to the
legislation and uh legislative body and
ask to have specific sections each time
added in
thank you uh representative Hicks
I support this bill I think this is
something especially if your
municipalities that are not considering
these issues I think this just brings
this to their attention
if it's not needed then it also doesn't
hurt and so I see no reason to oppose it
representative Manchester
thank you Mr chair
um I too will oppose itl this is a
master plan so it's like the blueprint
for America this is a blueprint and not
uh shelled so this is very needed in
terms of how fast the technology energy
sources and other sources Transportation
you name it things are changing in a
rapid rate in this day and age in 21st
century if you are stuck with
10 year old 10-year behind that's a huge
handicap
for any municipality to function agile
and
embrace the efficient new
approaches to solving Municipal problems
and I think this is a great win so I
would oppose itl and I would
request our
um encourage my colleagues on both sides
to take a hard look and support uh art
to pass
representative yocella
thank you
um
I consider the master plan to be the
central Plan central planning and it
costs money
um and the voters don't have a vote on
what is in the master plan it is created
by
um either uh
Regional commissions that we pay
um so it costs taxpayer money or it's
created directly from the budget
committee
or not the budget committee the planning
board
and approved by the planning board and
so
there's no real reason that they
could not put in any ordinance
or propose any ordinance the the
planning board is the the board that
proposes ordinances so they would be
able to propose an ordinance even
without the master plan going into and
spelling out what they should do because
they are the ones that actually tell
themselves what they should do in their
Central plan
um so I don't think that this is
actually necessary I think it's just
paperwork and spending
um money uh for the the planning board
to tell itself what to do and they can
already make their own decision and so I
don't believe that this is necessary
for that reason I'm voting itl thank you
thank you representative for the
comments representative priests and I
wasn't going to speak because everything
that I was going to speak on has been
spoken but after the last remark there's
a lot of misinformation about master
plans that I want to correct and number
one it is a guidance for the future
development of the community and all
master plans are developed by the
residents of that Community they take an
active part from the very beginning of
what's in that master plan and this bill
is only giving them some more options to
consider it's not a mandate it's just
merely options
every Community is going to be
developing in the future and and this
bill it's just giving them options to
consider when they're developing their
guidelines in their master plan thank
you
thank you for the comments
seeing none uh make a quick one
the master plan sections of the rsas
um Roman numeral 2 talks about master
plans and what must
they contain
67423 which we're talking about here
says may and during discussions it was
my interpretation that that may is a
suggestive May rather than a restrictive
which to me means may you can do it
pretty much anything you want under that
consider anything you want
um
and what has happened over the years is
that our RSA obviously had has grown
into yet another long laundry list of
additions
when I look at the the item Q there any
other section addressing any other topic
relevant to the appropriate future
development and on and on to me
you could eliminate everything in that
section
a through the new proposed p
and Implement some form of a cue and
that would take care of anything I I
oppose continuing to add
laundry lists of items that suggest
maybe what you could do when I believe
the planning boards can actually do that
I've actually talked to uh
representative stavis that um
I would be more than happy next year to
put in a joint um bill that would
simplify it down to something as easy as
any other section or any other item
wishing to be addressed by
by the um
on the master plan so I I Rise and
supported the Ito thank you
for the comments questions seeing none
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
HP 90 itl Vice chairman power yes
represents Guthrie
click votes yes representative lasalles
yes
uh representative Keller yes
representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes
representative cocom yes
representative Cahill
representative Davis no
representative Petro
represent 311. no representative Gilman
no reference majority no
Representative no represent Gallagher no
representative Hicks nope
representative Howland now
representative priests no and Mr
chairman yes
10 to 10.
okay so we have a ital motion that came
out tied
much like our other
bills earlier this morning
we can make some more motions or we can
allow it to go without recommendation is
there any other further
motions
seeing none it'll go on the calendar as
without recommendation
for
those in favor of the itl representative
Cahill be writing the committee report
and representatives Davis will write the
uh other report
okay that uh is hb90 the executive
session is closed on that so
a couple housekeeping items first
um
as you know yesterday we finished all
our public hearings on 49 bills I want
to commend this committee but I think
we've been doing awesome work it's been
really really good
um after today we have one further day
scheduled for executive session that
will be next Wednesday next Wednesday it
will start at 10 30 just like today did
it will be an exhaustive day we will
have 18 bills that we are going to try
to exact on that day I have also
schedule this room for Thursday morning
just in case we get to late in the
afternoon and we still have a long way
to go
so that is the plan for next week
um
I believe that's all I have
representative statements
yes thank you Mr chair I would also like
to commend the chair and the vice chair
for um the work that they have done to
expedite our hearings and our executive
sessions I think that um we've
accomplished a lot of good work and we
have more work to do but um
feel we are working very well together
and I'm grateful for that
thank you likewise
okay seeing nothing else we'll close
today and we will see you all next well
actually we'll see you Tuesday at the
house session
Mr Mr chairman yes sir I just received a
tweet about the work of the committee
today
if I could share that with a committee
is it good yeah
it says
Gallagher tosses his recycling bill in
the trash
well I don't know if that was a good one
anyway I'm sorry Eric
we have nothing on Tuesday right
we don't right on the house we have a
house oh no no we don't have any bills
yes we will have no house uh no bills on
the house floor only because everything
we've execed today it's too late to get
into a calendar so it'll be at a future
date that's true
thank you everybody